I never cared much about investing so I
was sitting on cash that I had saved up
from working on this business for the
past five years and I realized that I
should figure out what to do with this
money because as many great investors
say when there's blood on the street
that's the best time to buy I ended up
spending three to four hours every
single day just devouring all the
finance and econ material that I could
get my hands on I remember binge
listening to an eight hour long book on
the history of money in one sitting and
what's funny is that this was basically
the same material that I was studying
back in college but this time around I
was able to do it effortlessly my
motivation was so high that I didn't
even have to try how is this possible
well it all comes down to a concept that
I've recently been digging into called
woo way woo way is an ancient Chinese
philosophy which directly translates
into the Art of Doing Nothing or the
Arts of non-forcing now this doesn't
actually mean that you should do nothing
Wu weighs more about aligning your life
in a way so that things feel effortless
follow us for more helpful tips